[music]
>> Hello, hello.
Um
All right. So, let's get started.
I want to give
this presentation and tell you a new
perspective on
how to build foundation models.
And I want to
talk to you about this new perspective's
impact
in the society.
And at the same time, at the very end,
I'm going to leave you with one open
problem
that everybody is trying to solve right
now,
uh and hopefully open up some
um
uh
you know, light for you to really think
about, you know, like how where where do
you go from here?
So, early on when we saw the results of
pre-training foundation models, like
from the OpenAI's of the world and
DeepMind's of the world,
um one objective foundation model
companies emerged with one objective of
intelligence at all costs, you know, so
maximizing intelligence along one axis
to really get to the most kind of um
intelligent systems that we can get.
Like to the marketing term for it is
AGI, you know, this is where everybody
wants it to get.
But along the way, recently we have seen
that
this maximizing intelligence at all
costs
is coming with a certain type of
challenges.
And those challenges are
uh basically the limitations that we
have around compute, chips, and the
market that we're seeing right now.
Memory prices are actually going up. And
uh you're getting limited on how uh how
to deploy these solutions like at scale.
You're seeing that efficiency as an
afterthought is not is not a solution.
You cannot just have rely on scaling AI
systems and then have, let's say,
post-talk quantization kind of methods
to actually optimize your solutions.
You have to think about efficiency from
scratch when you design AIs.
And you've seen recently that there are
governance, compliance, and safety on
distribution of intelligence that
actually is a blocker on actually taking
AIs to the next step.
You have also seen that the open-source
AIs are getting a lot more powerful.
Like for the foundation model company,
it is something for them to think about.
So, distribution through open source
itself is also another uh challenge that
we need to think about.
So, to solve this,
we thought about
a new framework.
We thought about a three-axis problem on
building foundation models.
And how do you do that? Not just having
like intelligence maximization,
but when you design foundation models
from scratch, think about
intelligence from the pure capability
point of view, but also think about
efficiency of this computation from
scratch in terms of computational cost
of intelligence. For example, we have
the transformer architecture powering
all the AIs of today. We can also change
that. We can start thinking about uh
innovations across architecture to
getting more efficient uh realization of
intelligence. And at the same time,
think about where this intelligence
system is going to be hosted you know,
in the physical world. Because right
now, all the solutions that are like
foundation model companies are focused
on have been like dominated in the data
centers, but there is actually an
abundance of uh resources outside of
data centers in the physical world as
well.
So, if you have an objective function
that can allow us to
build efficient general-purpose AIs at
every scale,
this is basically the new framework that
we built
liquid AI on top of. So, we are a
foundation model company that actually
works across optimization of these three
axes.
How does it look like in practice?
The way we design AI, we put matters of
let's say foundation model development
across architecture, learning
algorithms, data efforts, all of this is
stack.
And we basically loop that with the
physical world.
When I say physical world, it starts
from chips, from systems like mobile
phones and laptops that you communicate
with the physical work through them, and
to let's say devices like robots, cars,
and anything else that moves in our
society.
So, and we co-build an optimization loop
between the substrate, which I call like
those kind of devices,
and the innovations that we have on the
research side.
Doing this with a meta AI algorithm, so
at the company itself,
we built a meta AI system. This AI
system is actually like a search-based
algorithm that at the same times across
the three axes that I actually
introduced for you, it actually
optimizes through those axes. Minimum
amount of memory, imagine given a
processor on top of which you want to
deploy the AI,
minimize the amount of error
while minimizing memory usage
while enhancing kind of the speed of the
models as an optimization problem. This
is basically AI is designing AI, you
know, so that's kind of the framework
that about three and a half years ago
like spun out of MIT we have started
like developing.
So, the core technology at my company is
all about basically building
optimization platforms across three
different axes: substrate, intelligence,
and efficiency. These are kind of the
three places is we go.
There's a I also put like a you know,
research um
paper here for you to have like a look
at like from 2024 to really see how we
are thinking about this automated
foundation model design as a whole.
Now, let's talk about the impact of this
um
systems.
As a result of our automation foundation
foundation modeling platform, we are
getting into something that we call
liquid foundation models. These are a
new class of artificial intelligence
systems that are very lightweight and
they can fit even on a Raspberry Pi.
So, you can host these models on the
smallest unit of compute and larger.
The systems are actually extremely
popular. These models has been
downloaded over with a rate of over 1
million downloads per week.
So, we are like from the US side, we are
actually like probably from the Open
Weight Lab in the top 10 kind of
companies that are actually releasing
open source models.
And we have done that with an amazing
amount of efficiencies.
Now, let's look at some stats. When you
optimize foundation models from scratch
with the goal of
three things as I mentioned, memory,
latency, and quality at the same time,
you can unlock new Pareto frontiers.
Here what you see is a comparison
of a bunch of models across quality on
the Y axis and on the X axis you see the
decode speed or the speed of
computation. The speed should be higher
and quality should also be higher. You
can see a comparison between like how
these models are actually performing.
At the same time,
this is another graph, very similar
thing that on the X axis you see
quality, on the
Y axis you see
um memory.
The lower memory footprint is better.
So,
we have a range of models ranging from
like 100 million parameter models to,
let's say, 100 billion parameter models.
So far, we have actually released some
of these models in open in an open
weight fashion.
And this is a report from artificial
analysis that you can actually see the
fastest models on the planet right now.
There's a Mercury 2 and there's a liquid
foundation model LFM2 on the second
instance. And from the price point of
view, this is kind of the cheapest
foundation model that you can actually
get.
The reason why we can actually unlock
such efficiencies is because of
the three axis kind of perspective that
we have. Maximize intelligence
while having a look into efficiency of
models and at the same time caring about
where intelligence is going to go.
Now, let's get out of this benchmarking
kind of
situation and talk about markets.
When you have models that can be running
on any kind of silicon, like on CPUs,
GPUs, or neural processing units, you
would be able to host them on devices.
So, you can go into automotive business,
you can go into mobile, you can go into
laptops, you can go into wearables, you
can deploy models and intelligence
across many, many different pipelines.
And there is a lot of processors in the
world. In fact, there are like 2 billion
processors every year every year getting
constructed outside of data centers that
you can put intelligence on top of.
And we are actually like enabling
intelligence on top of those surfaces.
The value of having fast models, models
that are designed for a smaller
processors, is the fact that you can
also run them in the cloud. The more
compute you give them, the faster
operation that a lower latency kind of
profile you get. So, you can also like
host them in constrained environments
when you do not have access to massive
or abundance of compute.
For example, in the automotive business,
which is one of the verticals that we
work with,
we are on the path that by 2028 be on 50
million cars
enabling
basically um
in-car intelligence.
The thing that that you know like
imagine an interface where you have like
your car is actually one of those
private spaces where you can communicate
with your car and control your car
completely with your voice and also like
with with let's say sensor kind of
infrastructure that allows you to really
have full-blown experience of a
of an intelligent system.
We are actually hitting on a laptop
1,400 tokens per second as a web
browser. So you can actually put our
technology, this is actually a hugging
face demo, that um you can actually try
it out. It's called web GPU. You can try
it out and you can actually get it on
your laptop up to like 1,400 tokens per
second systems that can actually solve
problems and call tools for you. You can
build agentic AI on a laptop with this
kind of speed.
We just recently um Shopify is one of
our clients and we just recently hit a
billion requests going through liquid
foundation models across the Shop app.
If you go to the Shop app in Shopify,
you can actually like whatever you you
type in there, it goes through a liquid
foundation model.
With AMD, we have been like
democratizing access to local
intelligence. For example, we're
building a specialized AI systems like
let's say a summarizer
that is really really a document
summarizer that is extremely good and it
only consumes about 800 megabytes of RAM
on a laptop and it can perform as good
as Claude Sonnet, like the best version
of the Claude Sonnet. So we are talking
about maximizing capabilities of a
specialized models without burning out
like basically on compute and cost.
And then there was a video here to show
that you can also get that these systems
power robots. For example, we had skill
selection layer for robotics. Like
that's something that we can enable like
on top of models because the models that
we are putting out there they are
multi-modal. They can process audio,
vision, text, and other formats of
signal.
So,
as I told you
as Liquid AI
as Liquid AI we're optimizing this
perspective of
before design of a foundation model
you're maximizing for efficiency
and you're maximizing for intelligence
while having efficiencies in mind, you
know, cost efficiency, compute
efficiencies, and at the same time the
substrate where intelligence can go
and design that as an AI designing AI
problem. Basically, a self kind of
recursive kind of self-improvement kind
of loop. And we have designed something
like that to really build an adaptive
layer on top of the silicon that is
outside of data centers. This way we can
actually bring intelligence to
everybody.
Now, I want to conclude my talk by
giving you
um
a question to think about, you know, we
have been known as Liquid AI as guys
that we have been like innovating across
architecture of intelligence. We have
not been building transformer-based
architectures. We have been uh
researching decade-long how can we learn
inspiration from brains to really bring
these inspirations back to machine
learning. Because your brain is
consuming it's a general-purpose AI your
brain and it consumes 20 watts of power.
So, if you can actually learn from
there, there are like a lot to actually
unlock.
So, think about like where we are.
There is an interaction when we design
this
highly powerful AI systems.
There are matters of architecture
innovations,
learning algorithms innovation, and data
effort innovation in place.
A combination of all of these things is
going to give rise to, you know, like
the most efficient way. So so far, we
have seen all these scaling a certain
type of this architecture, certain type
of learning algorithm, and certain data
efforts giving rise to basically where
we are today with the highest kind of
levels of
uh foundation models. But But there is a
zoo of opportunities to really explore
across this tree, and it's not only the
architecture that has to be explored.
I strongly believe through evolution,
intelligence emerged as a social
experience.
So think about it like this.
Intelligent behavior, it's an emergent
phenomenon. Nature actually gave rise to
intelligent beings because of like
maximizing survival capacity.
AI's foundation models of today are
systems that are
What we did, we tried to actually build
a process called next token prediction
as a learning algorithm.
And that next token at
next token prediction gave us a
capability or an emergent capability in
AI models or in neural networks called
in-context learning.
In-context learning was emerged from a
scaling next token prediction as an
algorithm. So we started from next token
prediction, we ended up with where we
are today.
And this in-context learning implements
a pseudo gradient descent pseudo
optimizer, you know? So it's getting
very technical.
But what I want to What I want to
mention is that there was a prior that
gave us to the emergent properties of
learning systems.
As I mentioned, human brain has a
massive um
your capabilities of different types of
learning. For example, you can learn
from examples. You can learn in short
period of time and in long form of time.
You can actually listen to something and
at the same time speak and at the same
time adapt. You're There are massive
types of uh neural architectures that
are happening in your brain that are
giving rise to intelligent behavior. So,
that many mechanisms of learning are
emergent properties of natural
evolution. This is actually what
happened.
Now, the question the fundamental
question that we have to ask is this.
What should we start with
from which
we can emerge multiple kind of learning
schemes. What is that algorithm that we
have to start with to really get to the
place where you have multiple learning
algorithms emerge?
Because if you start mimicking
reinforcement learning like with a
reinforcement learning pipeline or
building mimicking behavior is just
going to give you a mimicry machine.
They're going to be capable,
but they're not going to give you the
maximized basically intelligence
at all They're going to give you
maximized intelligence at all costs.
They're not going to give you an
efficient form of intelligence that is
basically we're talking like powerful
AI.
What we want to get at is to really
deeply think about what kind of priors
we can start a learning process
and what combination of these tools that
we are seeing across architecture,
across learning algorithms, and data
effort would give rise to that
format of intelligence.
Okay? And
my goal is to give you that question and
and and really justify through that
perspective of really there is a big
open question still how can we build
something that is actually as efficient
as your human brain and being able to
perform multiple mechanisms of learning
and actually exhibit behavior like
humans.
Thank you.